all right tonight's brief Hannity
history lesson the current DOJ rules
governing the reports release by the way
the Attorney General has full control he
decides nobody else but they were widely
back by the Democrats remember two
decades ago after the Starr report was
released and what the Democrats wanted
was designed to make the Special Counsel
more accountable to the public
how ironic the same people that wanted
to limit the release following Starr's
findings are now pushing to get the full
report no reductions a democratic stunts
like this don't stop there as they're
now taking steps towards get this
issuing subpoenas for mullahs report and
by the way they want grand jury
interviews and material which would be
illegal last time I checked joining us
for the very latest house freedom caucus
chairman mark meadows the author of an
introductory explainer to the Muller
report Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz is back with us all right let
me start with you professor last time I
checked
releasing Oh somebody's calling for one
of you releasing Grand Jury materials
that would be professional hello this is
Sean Hannity professor intertia was his
line can I help you before releasing
grand jury but that's illegal
correct and redactions for sources and
methods and maybe people who are
innocent in all of this whose names are
mentioned that would be normal although
Bart doesn't have to reveal a thing does
he know there's there's nothing in the
regulations that require him to reveal
anything and the best test is the shoe
on the other foot test when we go back
to call me statement if Comey had said
we're just not going to indict Hillary
Clinton on the emails and the
Republicans said wait a minute we heard
you have a report that says she was
extremely careless we want you to
release that the Democrats would have
jumped up and down and say no no
prosecutors don't say anything negative
about people they haven't indicted all
they're supposed to do is announce no
indictment well suddenly everything has
changed and it's the Democrats who want
to know why there wasn't charges they
want to know what the split was
between those who wanted a charge and
not charge an obstruction of justice the
law doesn't authorize that to be
released if the Attorney General wants
to do it that's within his discretion
but no court should order the Attorney
General in the executive branch to
release grand jury material and other
material to the legislative branch
certainly without the approval of the
court so where we're seeing rampant
apocrypha and we've seen on both sides
after Shore on the other foot I think
we'd see police are calling for the
release of material of the Democrats
yeah and you know I've agree with trey
Gowdy I don't think they should release
any of the congressman meadows it was
definitive on collusion if collusion not
a crime and you know okay so the
Attorney General and even rod Rosenstein
agreed in very quick order not based on
any principle that whether or not or
argument that you can indict a sitting
president on the merits they said no
this doesn't rise to any level of
indictment but grand jury materials not
eliminating executive privilege sources
methods innocent people frankly the
Democrats said we shouldn't do it I
think maybe they're right in this case
let's give them what they wanted well
you know it's amazing what a little bit
of good news for president Trump will do
to my Democrat colleagues you have Adam
Schiff chairmanship who as you as you
pointed out was saying no we can't
release anything that's classified we
can't we can't afford to put our
national security in jeopardy but yet
here he says I don't care what's in
their release at all you got Jerry
Nadler who's switched and flip-flopped
and said now he's going to subpoena this
even grand jury material listen both
sides look at this differently but I can
tell you right now this is all about a
narrative a narrative that the Democrats
have had for 22 months there that went
away that because their lies were not
born out in the Moller report and now
what they're trying to do is change the
narrative and pick and choose little
parts so that they can go after the
president once again congressman there
are going to be criminal referrals
issued this week by Chairman Nunez there
are going to be the president
interviewed last week there will be the
FISA applications released there will be
three oh twos released there will be
gang of eight material we took we've
identified five buckets of information
that will be extraordinarily damning I
know that to be the case based on all of
my sources is that a good idea for cuz I
think you want to be you want
transparency I don't think they're gonna
like that when that comes out well
they're not gonna like that Shawn but I
think you've got the professor on
tonight it's all about civil liberties
and making sure those civil civil
liberties are protected and if we cannot
count on our government to protect those
precious rights to privacy without you
know warrants and and warrantless
searches then we've got a real problem
in so some of those criminal referrals
are justified certainly some of the
declassification that gets to the bottom
of this is justified at the same time we
do need to protect our national security
interest a counter percent and sources a
minute you know the most offensive let
me ask you though I want to ask you this
they're gonna call back now to
re-interview many people they don't make
a lot of money a good attorney in
Washington I'm imagining as close to a
thousand dollars an hour what for the
same questions for how many times most
people be harassed like this and why
don't they just say I plead the fifth
I stand by my prior testimony well they
shouldn't plead the fifth because that
for many people implies guilt remember
that when the house on American
Activities Committee and the Senate did
that back in the McCarthy period the
courts finally put an end to it and said
enough is enough
you can't just harass people and call
people in order to expose them you have
to have a lot of let's remember
something from testimony a year and a
half ago they decide if it's perjury or
lying it cuz no question perjury traps
can perjury traps can be fallen into by
innocent people if an innocent person
testifies truthfully and somebody else
testifies the other way and if
prosecutors choose to believe the other
person you've flown into a perjury trap
which is why the president was right not
to testify to Mullen a person why I
think civil libertarians ought to be
very concerned about expose
to criticism one-sided report which only
saw one side of the story
and didn't result in indictments that's
traditionally not done and at least the
courts have to be asked to come in and
decide what can be shown and what can't
that come from grand juries let's have
the same symbol that maybe Democrats
might want to give up on the same
investigation they had the FBI
investigation to congressional
investigations no collusion no
obstruction give it up maybe solve
problems and serve the people that put
you there just an idea
thank you both I'm in favor of that